las primeras versiones hablan de al
menos seis misiles que fueron lanzados
esta mañana sobre el puerto de la ciudad
de odessa sin embargo las autoridades
hablan de 42 de ellos fueron
interceptados y dos de ellos habrían
alcanzado el puerto de la ciudad de
odessa donde están todas estas reservas
de grano que iban a empezar a ser
exportadas después de que ayer tanto
rusia como ucrania hubieran llegado a un
acuerdo con la intermediación de turquía
y las naciones unidas para desminar
estos puertos y empezar la exportación
de este grano a través de estos puertos
sobre el mar negro las primeras alarmas
las prendió uno de los parlamentarios de
la ciudad yo de saque en telegram
anunció este ataque y obviamente
denunciando la actitud de las fuerzas
rusas de las que ya decían los
ucranianos ayer que no se podían confiar
las presiones que nos llegan de la
ciudad es que hay bastante columnas de
humo en las cercanías del puerto y que
sintieron esas explosiones esta mañana
cuando se cumplen 150 días desde que
inició la invasión ordenada por el
presidente vladimir putin y también
madrugada sola no las alarmas en todo el
país especialmente en el centro una de
las grandes ciudades en las cercanías de
la ciudad de de niro allí cayeron 13
misiles cerca a una base aérea militar y
se habla que también hay bastantes
muertos y heridos aunque todavía las
cifras no han sido divulgadas